[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com we have to sort of accept
something that for a lot of Americans
and people who live in the United States
may be sort of difficult to accept I
know there's people in the audience that
this will be a difficult realization to
come to the United States is rapidly
losing superpower status over what has
been a disgustingly incompetent response
to the virus pandemic back when Donald
Trump was first elected president we had
sort of this conversation where we said
who now becomes the leader of the free
world and again the leader of the free
world it's not a formal designation it's
just a colloquial term it dates back to
the Cold War and it more or less means
who is the head statesman of Western
democratic nations and it's basically
been the President of the United States
de facto for a long time but
increasingly under Donald Trump and we
discussed this three years ago the
leader of the free world has
increasingly been German Chancellor
Angela Merkel and again it's not a
literal desert than a formal title it's
a colloquialism the new discussion is no
longer who is the leader of the free
world it's not it's not Donald Trump
that's clear it's more about the u.s. is
rapidly losing superpower status over
our inability to properly deal with
coronavirus and are embarrassing moral
failings which are highlighted every
single day by Donald Trump's gongshow
press briefings we'll talk about that
later where he brags about ratings and
you know brings up religious nuts to
speak and praise him rather than
presenting the sort of sober fact-based
information that is being done not just
by many of our own governors but
if you look around the world you see
Germany you see France you see Canada
and many others their leaders are
actually doing serious inform
informative press conferences for their
populations the u.s. is losing influence
Trump was slow
Trump was unprepared Trump was focused
on phrases like Chinese virus and
bragging about how soon we're going to
have zero cases we now have around
200,000 close to 200,000 governors can't
get the supplies that they need they're
not coming to us for help
meaning other countries we don't appear
to know what we're doing so why would
anyone come to us now Trump insists
everyone's coming to us it's not true
and this perception that you must have
American competence if you want to
properly deal with the problem around
the world that was a reality for a long
time during a crisis other countries
would say we've got to be involved with
the US let's get help from the u.s.
let's get guidance that is fading very
quickly in the era of coronavirus now
we've already talked about this in terms
of climate change the world no longer
comes to the US and often doesn't even
involve the US when we're dealing with
climate change under Donald Trump they
ignore us
Trump bailed on the Paris climate
Accords Trump has loosened emissions law
the EPA has now suspended pollution law
we'll get to that later regulations
rather than law and Trump has said
climate change is a hoax created by the
Chinese so we're out right we are not a
superpower when it comes to climate
change anymore
now on the virus the decline of the US
as a superpower is very very clear China
is sending ventilators and teams to
Italy they're sending masks to Belgium
Germany has had a plan that has held
down the death rate dramatically Germany
was early on testing when it comes to
European countries South Korea mitigated
the curve the most powerfully remember
South Korea and the US had their first
cases on the same day a lot of people
believe South Korea had a situation way
earlier no it was the same day they
immediately developed a test they
established
beaver clinics they established Proactiv
family quarantine and isolation
we didn't we're behind the curve we're
the ones who need help from other
countries the u.s. is not the beacon
that the rest of the world is trying to
emulate on foreign policy we are not the
beacon that the world wants to emulate
on dealing with climate change and we
are certainly not the beacon that the
world wants to emulate on coronavirus
the only emulators of the u.s. lately
are terrible the nationalist Indian
Prime Minister Kim jong-un Mohammed bin
Salman odo on right the people now
emulating the US and our leader are not
the Democratic Western leaders that we
are accustomed to because they can't
look to Trump they would fail if they
mirrored Donald Trump's leadership or
lack thereof the ones that do are the
cartoonish morons right the Brazilian
president who insists like Trump that
the media's lying to them about the
virus or whatever the case may be
we're quickly becoming a joke and it's
heartbreaking I take no pleasure on this
I know people on the right keep
contacting me saying David you're
gleeful at the death told you're gleeful
at the stock market crash no no no no
it's quite the opposite it's
heartbreaking and the rapidly climbing
death toll is part of that heartbreak we
may quickly have a situation in about
three to four months where the rest of
the world starts lifting travel bans but
they have to keep the u.s. banned
because we have no idea what we're doing
or at least Donald Trump doesn't Mexico
might all of a sudden say hey we want to
pay for a wall I'm kidding right but but
the the in the literal literal sense I'm
kidding we should be out there leading
the fight against the virus rather than
falling further and further behind with
a clueless clown doing daily press
briefings where he attacks journalists
self congratulate s--
and does all the things that he's been
doing Trump is failing because we don't
have the tools that are right for the
job we have a president who looks to
bomb things but you can't bomb the
coronavirus we have a president who
thinks of drones
you can't drone the corona virus you
can't bribe anybody people need to stay
home we need to proactively secure
medical equipment Trump didn't we needed
to develop a test early Trump didn't we
to use the media to get the danger of
the virus out not to try to hide the
danger of the virus which Donald Trump
did crises are Trump's kryptonite and
this is a big one and it's a sad reality
for the United States we are counting on
we're relying on our governor's to get
us out of this some of them are doing a
good job some are not and we'll see
where that goes
remember that in times of vulnerability
in times of chaos and times of strife
you've got to be really careful about
people who are looking to take advantage
of the situation and we've already
pointed out a lot of the individual
grifters selling bogus virus cures Jim
Baker Alex Jones we talked about those
claiming to pray away the corona virus
for money Kenneth Copeland to
televangelist we've talked about all of
that but today I want to talk to you
about a big grift those are small grifts
I want to tell you about the big grift
right now and grift doesn't even cover
it the EPA the Environmental Protection
Agency is suspending the enforcement of
her Virant of environmental rules over
the corona virus the EPA told companies
they will not have to meet environmental
standards during the corona virus
pandemic there's no end date on that
policy indefinitely but the one thing is
they have to be able to justify not
meeting the environmental rules and
regulations on the basis of the virus
which is very very easy to do so for now
there's no penalty for non-compliance
with routine monitoring and routine
reporting obligations so this means that
while things are crazy with the virus
companies can effectively pollute the
air pollute our
do all the things that we later learn
leads to increased cancer rates and
accelerating climate change in all of
that stuff the only rule is you have to
be able to plausibly justify it because
of the virus now of course a beautiful
loophole is right there as long as you
can say it's because of the virus you're
okay
and here's the incredible beauty of it
you can say well we don't know how much
we've been polluting because we've not
been able to monitor the pollution
and because of the virus now I'm not
saying it's not true to a degree that if
you're talking about social distancing
work from home all this stuff it's
plausible it would affect a company's
ability to monitor pollution and the
other view No so on and so forth but the
question is why is the EPA loudly saying
this like okay
imagine the EPA realizes how you know
what some companies aren't going to be
able to monitor we aren't going to be
able to successfully monitor the
companies because the EPA itself is
socially distancing or whatever but you
don't have to tell everybody right don't
tell them because when you tell them
you're literally saying go pollute do
whatever it takes to make as much money
as possible right now the reason why
sadly is that industry has successfully
lobbied the EPA the oil industry has
been lobbying the EPA to say suspend the
rules and nounce a suspension of the
rules the hill reports that the American
Petroleum Institute big oil lobby asked
that rules be suspended which require
repairing leaky equipment and monitoring
for air pollution and seepage into
nearby water it's another set of
grifters a big grift exploiting
coronavirus for their gain fortunes are
being made because of coronavirus
understand that and many more will be
made you can now pollute you won't get
in trouble so why the hell not it's
disaster politics 101 it becomes a cash
grab get your friends contracts Trump
now having the government buy masks from
the my pillow lunatic who's a trump
sycophant I'll tell you about that later
do a bailout but 2/3 of the bailout goes
to a few corporations and not to people
cancel environmental rules and penalties
open the floodgates for your friends in
industry to start polluting and grabbing
cash horrible horrible stuff predictable
disaster politics 101 April 9th okay
next Thursday we are going to do a huge
membership drive drive this is gonna be
a one day membership drive okay we're
having some issues as a result of the
virus
YouTube revenues down about 3540 percent
because so many advertisers have pulled
out to big advertisers of ours are
either cancelling or postponing ad
campaigns a lot of people are tighten
tightening the belt and canceling
memberships which I understand
so next Thursday April 9th we're going
to do a 1-day membership drive to try to
sort of kickstart things it'll be a huge
discount get notified about it by
getting on our mailing list at david
pakman.com really easy more information
about that coming later in the week
Thursday April 9th David Pakman show
membership drive in the meantime make
sure you're following me on Twitter let
me know what you're doing to stay busy
during the quarantine at Pakman on
twitter the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
gay are edith Buxton and Matthew and
Driessen edith and matthew thank you
thank you for your support
grabbing a membership at join pakman.com
also want to say thanks to mark
Hostelling who has been a member for
five years just under five years and is
today's longtime sustaining member of
the day
grab a membership today at join
pakman.com or get on our mailing list on
my website and you'll be notified on
April 9th of a huge membership special
over the last 48 hours we have seen an
incredible shift where Donald Trump has
signaled that if only 200,000 people die
of coronavirus in the United States that
would be considered a very good job we
are seeing such a goalpost move here
that it might actually trick his
followers because of how drastically the
goal posts are being moved I want to
remind you we have an incompetent failed
response to the virus this has resulted
in Trump's last tool so to speak which
is gaslighting his followers so that
they will hopefully forget that just a
few weeks ago Trump was talking about
we've got 15 cases and that number will
soon be zero other countries were acting
like adults they were preparing for the
pandemic here is Trump Sunday saying you
know if we end up with no more than
200,000 people dying not cases deaths
okay that would be a very good job and
Trump sort of cleverly mentioning you
know one estimate said 2.2 million might
die if we can keep it to 200,000 deaths
that would be a big very good job that
we did but not so you're talking about
2.2 million deaths 2.2 million people
from this and so if we could hold that
down as we're saying to a hundred
it's a horrible number maybe even less
but to a hundred thousand so we have
between a hundred and two hundred
thousand we all together have done a
very good job but so recall that Trump
tweeted on March 9th that this is
nothing compared to the flu because the
flu might kill 27,000 to 70,000 people
saying quote so last year 37 thousand
Americans died from the common flu it
averages 27 to 70,000 per year
nothing is shut down life and the
economy go on at this moment there are
546 confirmed cases of corona virus with
22 deaths think about that now at the
time 22 deaths now
3,000 and climbing in the United States
and the same Trump who said this isn't
as bad as the flu sometimes up to 70,000
dies of the flu each year rarely but
sometimes he's now saying if we stay
below 200,000 deaths not cases we will
have done a good job remember here was
Trump saying we have 15 cases and it
will soon be zero we've done really an
extraordinary job when you look at a
country this size with so many people
pouring in with the number one in the
world for people coming into a country
by far and we have a total of 15 cases
and again when you have 15 people and
the 15 within a couple of days is going
to be down to close to zero that's a
pretty good job we've done
and now if we don't lose more than
200,000 people
it means Trump did a very good job this
is a hell of a lot of deaths for
something that five weeks ago was
nothing and just the latest Democratic
hoax so it's really really important
that we don't take our eye off the ball
this is a pandemic this is a tragedy at
some point we will get past it
we will have some death toll the latest
estimates are about 83,000 for this wave
we could then have a second wave in the
fall and another wave in 2021 we could
get to 200,000 by the time it's all said
and done we don't know yet but at some
point it's going to be done we can't
forget the incompetence and the lying
and the deception and say hey we made it
those of us that do make it and
hopefully as many of us as possible will
be in that group we have to remember
that we've been led by one of the worst
responses in the world to the virus
maybe Iran did worse I don't know China
lied a lot sure but look at how quickly
South Korea developed and deployed a
test they had their first case on the
same day we did South Korea has a
hundred and 50 deaths total not in one
day total we have hundreds dying every
day it appears it will soon be thousands
dying per day we need to ensure that
there is a consequence for Trump and now
this framing that he's doing of listen
it's a big win if we keep the death toll
to 200,000 he previously said we have a
few cases it will soon be none we now
are having potentially hundreds of
thousands of deaths we can't let him get
away with it his followers are going to
we can't enough of us have to remember
that we need a change in November of
2020 so that he cannot get away with
this there are medical components here
there are social social cultural
components here economic there are so
many considerations but we've been
failed by the Trump administration and
there has to be a consequence for that I
don't know if there will be but I hope
there is hey so this is weird
it
seems that Donald Trump doesn't
understand the concept of per capita for
the last 10 days or so Trump keeps
bragging about how much the US is
testing for the virus and every time he
does he's ignoring the concept of per
capita or at least we thought he was
ignoring the concept of per capita
because it wasn't politically convenient
but based on yesterday's press
conference I'm increasingly thinking
Trump doesn't understand what per capita
means per capita of course is when you
adjust numbers for the size of a
population so if I say to you you know
the United States and Colombia both gave
away a hundred million dollars to people
in stimulus money per capita in the u.s.
that's 29 cents per person in Colombia
it's $2 per person because Colombia and
the US have different populations if we
say you know we did a million
coronavirus tests and South Korea did
500,000 might sound like we did more but
per capita South Korea did way more
because South Korea's population is much
smaller than ours we have 340 million
people in the u.s. South Korea has about
50 million people so check this out
yesterday reporter yummy shhhhh Alcindor
asked Trump about this and Trump says
we're testing more than anyone and yummy
Sh raises the issue of per capita and
Trump doesn't seem to get it he wrongly
states the population of Seoul South
Korea he talks about how we have rural
areas in the United States and it only
gets funnier and by funnier I mean more
tragic because we laugh to avoid crying
in these difficult times take a look at
the first part of the video
mr. president you said several times
that the United Sates is ramped up
testing but the United States is still
not testing per capita as many read as
many people as other countries like
South Korea why is that and when do you
think that that number will be on par
with other countries very much fun part
look look per capita we have areas of
country that's very wet I know South
Korea better than anybody it's a very
tight you know how many people are in
sold you now think the city of Seoul is
38 million people okay so that's like 10
seconds from Trump and there are just so
many things to look at there
Trump mentions hey but hold on a second
we have rural areas in the United States
and Seoul South Korea is really dense
per capita accounts for the population
that's the point of per capita Trump is
acting like the fact that we have rural
areas means we are testing more per
capita no we're talking about how much
are we testing relative to the
population which includes rural areas
and densely populated areas Yemi SH is
at least trying to talk about per capita
then Trump says he knows South Korea
better than anyone which is another one
of those hyperbolic lies but then again
immediately he miss states the
population of Seoul saying Seoul has a
population of 38 million for a guy who
knows the most about South Korea it's
weird not to know the population of
Seoul so it didn't sound right when
Trump said 38 million I looked it up
Seoul's population is only 9 million
almost 10 million so I thought well
maybe Trump was referring to the metro
area the Seoul metro area but that's
only 25 million so I thought well maybe
Trump meant all of South Korea has 38
million but no as I mentioned earlier
South Korea has about 51 million people
so then and this is just too funny if
you google Seoul South Korea this quick
facts things thing pops up and it says
38 M but that's the elevation of Seoul
38 metres above sea level or 125 feet
is it possible Trump is confusing
population and elevation or is he just a
[ __ ] who doesn't know anything in South
Korea is a not he's not actually an
expert in South Korea and he doesn't
understand the concept of per capita
maybe that's the most likely explanation
you be the judge here's the rest of the
back and forth with journalists Amisha
Alcindor that's bigger than anything we
have 38 million people all tightly-wound
together we have vast farmlands we have
vast areas where they don't have much of
a problem in some cases they have no
problem whatsoever we have done more
tests what I didn't I didn't talk about
per capita we have done more tests by
far than any country in the world by
four
our testing is also better than any
country in the world
so again Trump talking about how hey but
we have rural areas but again per capita
accounts for the total population and
the number of tests adjusted to the size
of that population imagine having a
president imagine having a president
guys I think it's time to reset the
simulation the founder of my pillow a
guy named Michael in Dell a right-wing
lunatic a total trump brown-nosing
sycophant he was invited to speak
yesterday at the White House coronavirus
press briefing and he praised Trump as a
gift from God to the United States if
you've not heard of my pillow maybe you
don't watch Fox News at 2:00 a.m. my
pillow is a foam pillow sold in
infomercials and often on Fox News
itself and my pillow is going to retool
there with some other factories to
manufacture masks for healthcare workers
which is great that's fantastic
Mike Lyndell was invited to speak during
yesterday's press briefing and he went
completely off the rails reading a
statement off of a crinkled piece of
paper that Trump is literally a gift
from God given to the United States in
November of 2016 check this out I wrote
something off the cuff if I can read
this
God gave us grace on November 8 2016 to
change the course we were on God had
been taken out of our schools and lives
a nation had turned his back on God and
I encourage you use this time at home to
get back to home to get back in the word
read our Bibles and spend time with our
families our president gave us so much
hope we're just a few short months ago
we had the best economy the lowest
unemployment and wages going up it was
amazing with our great president vice
president and this administration and
all the great people in this country
praying daily we will get through this
and get back to a place that's stronger
and safer than ever
please come I did not know he was gonna
do that but he's a friend of mine and I
do appreciate it why did God give us
Trump in November of 2016 and give us
the stock market and wages and all the
stuff Mike's referring to but then give
us coronavirus with nearly a million
confirmed worldwide cases nearly 40,000
deaths maybe more than 40,000 by the
time this clip gets published why
wouldn't God just not give us
coronavirus to begin with and we'd all
be far better off oh no David how dare
you god works in mysterious ways he gave
us Trump and coronavirus and he gave us
Trump to deal with Corona vine oh yeah
oh yeah get it sorry sorry
how dare I question that it's not funny
anymore if it ever was imagine having an
actual president who handles things like
an adult who in December and January
takes action instead of too little too
late in mid-march a president who talks
about the human toll at the press
briefings and tries to connect with
people and their struggles and the fact
that this is a very scary situation
instead we have a president who
disbanded the pandemic response team did
nothing until late February early March
turns his press press briefings into
promotions for exciting new products
that might appeal to coronavirus
customers as they've been referred to
while having corporate CEOs do promos
for themselves while claiming Trump was
a literal gift from God we are in
trouble and if you watch the briefings
not just of governor's here in the
United States but watch the briefings of
world leaders in other countries Justin
Trudeau in Canada Emmanuel macron in
France
uncle amiracle in Germany you very
quickly realize we don't have a leader
here we're depending on governor's the
ones that are competent to hopefully
save us because we've got no leadership
coming from the Oval Office and the gift
from God rant from the my pillow
sycophant it's I was hoping I would wake
up and that that wouldn't really have
happened yesterday but it did in the
is where we are today we'll continue
discussing this on the David Pakman show
instagram at david pakman show while
you're there follow me as well at david
pakman we'll take a quick break and be
back after this the david pakman show at
david pakman.com welcome back to the
david pakman show it's great to welcome
brian greene to the program today who's
a professor of physics and mathematics
and director of Columbia University's
Center for Theoretical Physics also
known for his groundbreaking discoveries
in super string theory and author of
many books including I believe most
recently it's until the end of time
right that's your latest yes that's
correct exactly so maybe to get into our
conversation when somebody maybe is
trying to understand not something like
super string theory or or the nuts and
bolts but more generally what types of
questions does your work seek to answer
to have a broader understanding of what
you're doing how would you explain that
to them well certainly in in in my the
newest book that you just made reference
to until the end of time the goal is to
give the curious person a sense of how
they fit within the cosmic hole I mean
the journey that I take in that book is
from the very beginning of time walking
through the sequence of steps that yield
life and conscious beings and on to the
very far future and within that cosmic
unfolding my goal is to give the person
a sense of where they came from
the environment that they're in now
where it came from and where things are
going with ultimately a new perspective
on why things matter does the day-to-day
of sort of like thinking of superstring
theory for example when you're working
on something like super string theory do
it feel like it's connected directly to
answering those questions or does it
feel like it starts to get removed and
sort of operate in a more theoretical
space well we like to use the big
questions as motivation we deeply want
to know the full story of creation the
full story of how the universe began
we'd love to understand the deep nature
of space and time these kinds of
questions are why many of us certainly
for me it's the case went into the field
in the first place
but your question is a good one because
when you're in the midst of doing the
research it's like any other subject the
detail the daily grind if you will can
often be fairly disconnected from the
big overarching goals so you know I have
students that come to me and they they
want to work in physics and all they
have in mind are the big huge questions
and when I describe them hate to make
progress toward those questions you got
to do mathematical calculations you've
got to do experiments you got to write
computer programs you got to do
simulations for many of them that's a
bit of a shock but that's the way you
make progress in the day-to-day sense
how would you sort of ballpark the
progress that has been made like over
the last 10 50 and 200 years on
answering some of these questions in
other words there's camps that say we're
never really going to know the origins
because we can't can't really go back in
a way that would give us those answers
there's others who say maybe we will but
like aside from the end point that we
may or may not get to what's the what's
been the progress that has been made
well it's been utterly stunning right if
you if you go to the furthest extent of
the timeline that you mentioned go back
200 years to say the early 1800s we were
just beginning to gain an understanding
of some of the most rudimentary forces
at work in the universe how electricity
and magnetism work the early experiments
are just taking place experiments on on
the nature of light these were vital
developments but when you compare them
with what we understand
today the insights that have come from
special relativity Einstein
general relativity again Einstein
quantum mechanics and on through the
developments in unification that have
swept through the 20th century and into
the 21st I mean right now we can do
mathematical calculations that tell us
what the universe was like a fraction of
a second after the beginning and then we
can use those mathematical insights to
make predictions for what those
conditions way back then should yield
for our observations today and many of
those predictions are borne out to
fantastic accuracy by powerful equipment
that we launch into space that takes the
temperature of the night sky that looks
deep into the heart of black holes so it
is stunning how far we've come in the
last 200 years what do you think has
been the effect of that on sort of the
human psyche as we exist in the world
and the reason I ask I mean it's it we
also it's hard to separate that from
technological advance medical science
changing so drastically travel like it's
it's difficult because those things have
also changed so much but what's your
sense of how our understanding and
day-to-day lives are different based on
what we now know that we did in 200
years ago well I don't think you can
give a uniform blanket answer for all
human minds there are some of us who are
deeply interested in these ideas even if
we're not doing research on the topic
and have allowed the insights of modern
science to affect our outlook on the
world
and given us the the laudable
perspective that there are true
qualities of reality that research both
experimental and theoretical equipment
together with say mathematical insights
can reveal there are others though who
enjoy the fruits of those undertakings
as you mentioned the technology that has
emerged from the deeper understanding
but have not taken in that mindset and
it's really unfortunate especially in
the city
that we find ourselves in today when
there are some who feel that reality
ultimately is a matter of opinion
it's not a matter of opinion I'm not
trying to downgrade the value of
opinions on certain issues but in terms
of true qualities of reality here on
planet earth and in the wider cosmos
there is such a thing as right and wrong
there is such a thing as fact and
fiction there is such a thing as
expertise that can yield insights that
can determine the correct course of
action on vital issues and not everyone
has taken in this basic quality of
scientific advancement over the past two
or three hundred years right well so I
mean now we have the the phrase
alternative facts is an interesting one
that that has surfaced and these ideas
of you know if I don't like your
conclusion I can just kind of reject the
premises that you use to build that up
do you think that that's been more
acutely weaponized recently in society
it certainly has especially when you've
got leaders who have that very
perspective or at least leaders who
leverage that perspective by using it as
a tool or as you describe as a weapon to
advance certain political perspectives
and that is deeply troubling and as
we're beginning to see has the capacity
to yield deep tragedy what's the
solution in your mind to that because
I've read some interesting pieces that
say it's not as simple as we have to
start teaching critical thinking and
philosophy and epistemology earlier that
there's a bigger divide and a bigger
picture issue than simply that I I agree
although I would say that that is part
of the solution I I I can't help the
optimistic side of my personality from
saying I just feel that if we could get
kids at an early stage to really
recognize the power of scientific
insight not abstract
but you know I've taught kids and I've
seen them undergo that transition from
confusion about something to mastery
even if it's a small element of math or
physics and that move from confusion to
clarity can be life changing
because your way of thinking about the
world and your recognition of your power
to understand the world can radically
change but I agree that's not the full
it's not the full solution because we
find ourselves in an era when many
people and by many I I don't exactly
know the number that I'm talking about
so don't hold me to sort of details of
numbers here but there is a segment of
the population that makes decisions not
based on thinking through policy but
rather who else is supporting that
policy it's the group think it's whether
or not you want to be in that group or
the other group as opposed to a rational
evaluation of policy and perspective and
that kind of identity politics needs to
needs to shift because that is not the
appropriate useful way to set policy
yeah I'm curious what you would think
about the motivations of oh so let's
just to give an example the tea party in
2010 right this was a movement that
succeeded to the extent that it did
because of individuals voting for people
who were pushing policies that were not
going to be good for them as individuals
but like Jonathan height for example
argues they were policies that they
identified as good for the group in
which they were members or you know
membership maybe is a bit of a too
formal a term for it isn't that kind of
individual versus group thinking a
factor in what you're describing here
it's huge it's exactly what I'm
describing you know if you were to and
Jonathan probably did because he is a
great social scientist and goes out and
gets the data Simon that they've
collected data if you interview the very
people who are supporting a given policy
and ask them why they are so
according it some will have thought it
through no doubt but many will not have
thought it through because that's not
the way that the decision is made rather
the decision is made in the manner that
you describe do you want to be
identified as being part of that group
of people who for whatever reason you
feel more of a kinship with or do you
want to break ranks with the group that
you feel that kinship with in order to
follow a policy that is not widely
accepted by the initial group and
unfortunately that kind of perspective
and that kind of decision-making is
prevalent and it's not the kind of
decision-making that ultimately is good
for the world so to step back from the
zoom out from this a tiny bit I have
this idea that maybe is very naive and
I'm curious what you think about it
which is if we were to make contact with
alien intelligence and find out it's
real if we were to figure out some of
the big answers that people in your
field are looking for about our our
place in the universe et cetera I have
this idea that issues like gay marriage
and debt and deficit and stuff like this
would evaporate because everybody would
immediately have this awakening as a
result of this new information that we
have is that incredibly naive would we
just kind of adjust and keep having the
same disagreements we're having well I
think the answer depends a lot on the
details right it's certainly the case
that having a common enemy is a powerful
force of unification fortunately and
unfortunately at the same time when we
can identify a common enemy it allows us
to bind together into an even larger
group if that will aid in our survival
and look many of our predilections
emerged from evolutionary pressures
across you know tens of thousands of
generations and the ability to come
together into socialized groups
has been an important means by which we
have gotten to our place of dominance in
the world so it's not surprising that we
have this sort of inbuilt reaction to
certain kinds of pressure certain kinds
of challenges and once its challenges it
is a common enemy but you know I like to
think that if we encounter the aliens
maybe it won't be an enemy maybe be a
very friendly relationship and if that
were the case maybe they would reveal
the deep truths that somehow the world
would listen to but I have a feeling
that it's in maybe over a long stretch
of time that might be possible but the
notion that I think you are articulating
that all of a sudden we sort of lift
ourselves up from thinking about all of
the issues here and all of this now is
sort of secondary to this larger kind of
conversation we're having having with
the aliens
I suspect that would not happen at least
not on the kinds of instantaneous
timescales that you have in mind well
part of what makes me doubt it would
happen at all is that humans seem to
have this incredible ability to just
adjust to what reality becomes and it
becomes the new baseline and things sort
of return to some kind of baseline in
some way ya know it's certainly the case
you know I was on an airplane you know
at JFK on the tarmac on September 11th
2001 and I could I saw the the plane hit
the tower from my seat in the plane I
had a clear shot right from you know
Queens into Manhattan and so there was a
sense at that moment that that the world
would completely change that nobody
would live their lives the way that they
once did and that was true for a while
and there certainly have been changes
that occurred by virtue of 9/11 without
a doubt but I think many people reverted
at least pretty close to the lives that
they led if they weren't directly part
of the tragedy or if they didn't have a
loved one who's directly part of the
tragedy we do have this you can call it
resilience this ability to sort of
revert back to the way that we once were
and so I I kind of a
with you that that is the the default
development that we certainly have seen
happen over and over again that we find
a way of sort of acclimating to the new
environment and taking our old lives and
getting it in to the new jigsaw puzzle
as best as we can and then going forward
from there let's pause our conversation
with professor of physics and
mathematics Brian Greene they're the
full conversation will be on the david
packard show youtube channel at
youtube.com slash the david packard show
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
I have good news for you today in that a
bad person lost their job but it's still
all wrapped in terrible news which is
that Fox News is still combining with
the Trump administration to continue
spreading violent disinformation about
the virus I'm talking now about former
Fox News host trish regan really a phial
person trish regan was until recently a
Fox Business Channel host she went on
one of the most unhinged Trump defending
coronavirus minimizing rants that we've
ever seen just a couple of weeks ago and
Fox has said bye-bye to her although we
don't yet know exactly why check out the
first part of this bizarre rant
everything about it is wacky and
deranged this was again a couple of
weeks ago when we knew this was a crisis
take a look we've reached a tipping
point the chorus of hate being leveled
at the president is nearing a crescendo
as Democrats blamed him and only him for
a virus that originated halfway around
the world this is yet another attempt to
impeach the president and sadly it seems
they care very little for any of the
destruction they are leaving in their
wake
losses in the stock market all this
unfortunately just part of the political
casualties for them you know this is the
time to be united not to be pointing
fingers not to be encouraging hate and
yet what do we see we see the absolute
opposite from the left tonight good
evening everyone i am trish regan the
hate is boiling over many in the liberal
media using and i mean using coronavirus
in an attempt to demonize and destroy
the president this monologue which
should really be Exhibit A and media
literacy classes for distinguishing
between news and opinion identifying
bias identifying unstable people maybe
in a psychology class
it went on for five minutes and really
it peaked at the end when Trish Regan
couldn't even keep her nonsense straight
off of the teleprompter sort of got lost
in her own teleprompter while continuing
to in a completely unhinged fact freeway
defend Donald Trump and minimized the
virus here's the wrap up to her lunatic
soliloquy
the media to spin a narrative that this
sell-off and this virus are all a result
of President Trump it's just wrong but
unfortunately I guess they needed
someone to blame they were looking for
someone to blame they want to blame him
for literally anything they can and they
have no real interest shall we say in
finding who's to blame who is the root
cause of all this from what we can tell
this all originated out of China
you know when Donald Trump is their
political target that's all they need
and that's tonight's Intel so the good
news is by by trish regan the bad news
is fox is still a disaster it's also not
clear that this rant is why she was
fired it may be it may not be fox has
only been saying you know we thank Trish
and we wish her continued success so we
don't even really know the full reality
of it one idea is that trish regan may
sort of be like the sacrificial lamb for
all of fox news because you've got the
Fox and Friends clowns in the morning
talking about flying around and going to
restaurants and wanting to get their
nails done you have sean hannity talking
about how vaping might protect you from
coronavirus and suggesting unproven
prophylactic treatments for the virus
according to reporter gabriel sherman
fox news is actually worried about
possible legal liability for their
coronavirus downplaying so maybe they're
tossing trish regan out of there to say
hey listen we took it seriously we
pulled her off the air we cut ties with
her we did the right thing while
allowing everybody else to continue
spouting the nonsense
so that's trish regan we do have one
more fox news related story today which
is about that lunatic right-wing judge
Jeanine Pirro
who appeared visibly drunk during her
weekend program also presumably being
produced from her home at this point so
let's talk about that one next so
there's this wacky former judge
she's a pro Trump judge named Jeanine
Pirro she does a weekend show on Fox
News I don't I think it might just be a
once a week show but maybe it's like a
Friday Saturday and Sunday show but but
I I would I believe it's just once a
week she appeared extremely impaired and
disheveled during her program over the
weekend and the speculation that's
running rampant is that she seemed to be
very very drunk
um first her show was delayed for
technical difficulties now presumably
that's something related to something
about her socially distanced studio it
was at really a technical issue but when
the show started judge Jeanine was
slurring her words she looked visibly
disheveled at one point she appeared to
be nodding off while her guest was
speaking and the idea now is is it
possible that Judge Jeanine was actually
drunk now
whether or not her drunkenness explains
the technical delay of the show we just
have no idea let's go to the first clip
she seems confused about what the next
segment is and as you can hear right
before but this is so crazy right before
the intro graphic cuts to her did you
actually hear her yell to someone off
camera somewhere I can't before she
starts confusedly reading the
teleprompter take a look at this
[Music]
all right wait joining us every time
that they came back from a commercial
break she seemed more impaired
check this out and here is a very
labored teleprompter reading from Judge
Jeanine
welcome back to justice just the other
day the president talked there was
hoping about the possibility of
reopening everything on Easter Sunday
and in a way where we could kind of come
out of this quarantine as loose as it
may be that were involved in and Lisa
booth the Fox News contributor is here
to talk with us tonight about whether
that's even a possibility how are you
Lisa so alcohol is the main thing that's
being mentioned quaaludes was the other
thing being thrown around sort of a
throwback to the wolf of wallstreet era
at another point she appears to be sort
of nodding off while her guest talks her
head kind of leaning more and more to
her left until she seems to kind of be
startled back into a higher level of
coherence so it's very weird and anyway
who knows what this exactly is but it
keeps happening
remember that Rudy Giuliani's evening
appearances on Fox News and other TV
stations were limited they tried to get
Rudy on during the day because his
evening drinking at dinner was becoming
a problem and he would then go on TV
after having had a few too many along
with one of those big cigars that he
likes last week maybe it was the week
before it's all blending together we saw
Trump economic advisor Larry Kudlow who
is known to have previously had pretty
severe drinking problems
he seemed impaired on television and now
judge Jeanine Pirro things are all just
crazy in the air of Carrera of
coronavirus and again I want to be
really clear alcoholism is nothing to
laugh at and in fact I think we need to
be taking extra care during this time to
mention a lot of people are under stress
anxiety depression cabin fever erratic
behavior because these are not normal
times I've never experienced anything
like this in my lifetime
most people alive today have never
experienced a sort of shutdown
quarantine isolation situation like this
at the global scale in in any of their
lifetimes and I understand
turning to whatever it is right some
we're hearing about people turning to
benzos we're hearing about people
turning to alcohol etc but whatever it
is that's going on at Fox News with the
drinking and the impaired 'no sand and
right-wingers who seem to be impaired on
TV it's getting a little bit weird and
it's more than just concerning let me
know what you make of the Jeanine Pirro
thing we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p
here's a very specific question about IQ
and donald trump hi David I'm a huge fan
of your show I watched you almost every
day I'm 24
I work in staffing and recruiting in
Houston right I'm look Y if you had to
guess what would you say from overall IQ
because if I had to guess I would say
it's at about ninety which maybe for the
average person it's not super low but of
course this president that is entirely
too low and you want to know something I
just don't feel he has the the IQ to do
the job so what are your thoughts what
would you think has overall i cuted
listen I don't really want to speculate
on Trump's IQ because the entire IQ
thing has been weaponized as as many of
you know with race IQ stuff with
overblowing the importance of IQ and the
connection of IQ to different measures
of success like what I can tell you is
Donald Trump clearly doesn't have the
temperament nor the knowledge nor the
attention span nor the personality to be
a good president he doesn't strike me as
a good person he doesn't seem able to
actually feel empathy he does not seem
to be able to engage in the sort of deep
learning and reading that is required
that
Obama was able to to engage in to be a
good president and that's where I would
focus my energy I have no idea what
Trump's IQ is there are lots of people
with a high IQ that are bad people and
therefore you still don't want them as
president so I I understand what you're
saying I think that I would approach it
sort of a different way which is Trump
has failed us as president regardless of
his IQ he could have a 160 IQ who knows
I don't care he's a bad president and
that's why he needs to be removed in
November okay
next Thursday April 9th we are going to
try to have a coordinated membership
explosion all right there's going to be
an email going out to everybody on our
mailing list at 2:00 p.m. Eastern 11:00
a.m. Pacific on Thursday April 9th with
a huge membership discount the biggest
discount of the year why are we doing
this on April 9th well couple things are
going on number one a lot of people are
canceling memberships because of
coronavirus and we don't want to reduce
ours we don't want to do layoffs we want
to just be able to keep things going and
so we want to kind of try to recover
some of those lost memberships we've
also had some advertisers that have had
to stop or cancel campaigns with us
because they aren't selling product so
they're not going to do advertising
right now and lastly April is the
anniversary of ad pocalypse 2017 so a
lot of the people who signed up in 2017
no doubt are going to have credit cards
that have expired and membership
payments that are going to fail so April
could be very ugly which is why on
Thursday April 9th at 2:00 p.m. Eastern
an email will go out with a huge
membership special I invite you to
participate sign up for our mailing list
you do it at david pakman.com top right
of the website you put in your email
address that's it okay don't email me
about this sign up at david pakman.com
and you'll be notified about this
special on Thursday April 9th join me on
the bonus show today we have updates
from the Pat producer Pat Ford Fiasco
involving a fire firefighters water a
collapsed ceiling it's a nutty story I
will give you the updates on today's
bone
and we have much more to discuss as well
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]